all right everyone it's official diamond
is unbreakable is my new favorite part
of jojo's bizarre adventure while it
didn't have the same world ending stakes
parts one two and
three had i didn't find my enjoyment
diminished even in the slightest
in fact i'd even argue that the approach
diamond is unbreakable took in telling
its story of this small town's troubles
served only to enhance the drama and
sense of tension throughout for me
ending on a touching moment that i
sincerely never saw coming and
when it did happen i didn't realize how
nostalgic this journey was
for me in other words this story was
significantly smaller in scope compared
to the three that came before it in many
ways
felt much more potent as a result and
today i want to explore what it was that
worked for me about the story
break down some of my favorite stand
battles and to finally hunt down and
stop
the dangerous man that wants to live a
quiet life
i'm tolerant mark and this is my review
for the unmistakable
unshakable diamond is unbreakable
[Music]
[Music]
i chase
[Music]
so earlier this week i was perusing the
comments section of my videos you know
it's something that i've gotten into the
groove of doing i enjoy reading through
everyone's comprehensive thoughts and
the material i spend an entire week
slaving over
[Music]
i don't know why i even try anymore i'm
of course kidding no you're not
i hate it when people get names wrong
too so i'll try harder in the future to
get these names correct
so after josuke used shining diamond on
deadly queen
all right okay so where were we oh yeah
last week mr hensey after his fight with
star platinum and echoes
went not so well he decided to make his
way to cinderella's where he killed
everyone who was there but not before
stealing a face and vanishing into the
crowd assuming a brand new identity
in my opinion this was a terrific idea
on behalf of araki and wouldn't you
believe it this half has even more great
ideas
speaking of which because the english
localization doesn't cover the majority
of this second half of the story
i will now be watching the anime's
adaptation as a substitute so
let's begin episodes 25 and 26 following
this unfortunate loss of contact with
the now newly disguised kira
jodoro and the gang decide to check the
first place anyone would for any
indication
of where he might go or to at the very
least learn more about him specifically
his home i don't really have any strong
feelings one way or the other about the
kira father character going by the name
of yoshihiro
i think his stan power and the
encounters that spawned forth from it
including the battle in the house were
creative and engaging as an audience
member but he also feels like a much
more shallow
implementation of a mechanic within the
story to keep kira's involvement to a
minimum until its climax time with him
effectively being the main culprit
responsible for all of the obstacles
that orientate themselves before our
heroes
on their quest for kira's newly acquired
identity and look i'll hold my hand up i
recognize that this is something that
the story requires
if the heroes were to find kira almost
immediately that's firstly anticlimactic
to the max and it's
not interesting at all so naturally
there needs to be some mechanism to
delay the discovery of kira somehow
however i just found this to be slightly
on the contrived side of things
what with him flying around town in a
photograph attached to a bird
shooting arrows left and right like some
sort of flat balled cupid
and this wouldn't bother me at all if
not for another part of the story that
makes itself known soon after but i'll
get to that in just a second
once general and josuke enter a room in
keira's old house looking for clues they
known as a camera suddenly snap their
picture and
somewhat creepily it pictures an old man
in the corner of the image they
recognized this man from photographs
dotted throughout the house as yoshihiro
kira's father figure who despite being
deceased is still alive within the
photographs and with him comes abilities
that restrict the motion of those within
the frame
of the picture taken however in a rather
quick fashion jotaro comes up with a
clever solution
and thus saves the day in this episode
this is a great example of what i think
this part does better than all the
others whilst part 3 and part 2 had
clever uses
of the respective power sets and systems
diamond is unbreakable's use of the
powers that occupy the pages are
phenomenal particularly with josuke that
i touched on before but i will be
definitely touching on again
later once this plan is full yoshihiro
flies off with the bow and arrow in
kirito's home and hitches a ride on
a bird sounds ridiculous and it is he'll
be causing all sorts of trouble from
here on in as he travels across the town
looking for people to shoot and activate
their stand for to protect his son but
strangely he seems to be the one that's
guided by the arrow that seems to have
its own autonomy and targets in mind and
its first target
this kid that's obsessed with rock paper
scissors apparently if nothing else this
encounter provides rohan a character i
really enjoy another opportunity to
shine in the spot to demonstrate his
cool powers and to overcome the forces
of this weird vortex
stand sucking power of the rock paper
scissors kit episodes 27
28 29 and 30. within this grouping of
four episodes we have two standalone
and two that act as a two-parter so
let's tackle these in order flying
around the town like the g from the
goosebumps intro yoshihiro sets his
sights on this lone individual walking
down a country road strangely however
this arrow only
dings off of his cheek seems to be made
of some material far more durable than
he anticipated and well
he's an alien and you'd think this would
be a massive deal that would have
massive ramifications for the entire
series but
it doesn't really it's it's an alien and
you know people care for like an episode
or two but he really he really doesn't
come up later oh my god and this alien
outs himself
as an alien almost immediately once he
runs into josuke and okuyasu randomly
as a side note i really enjoy okayatsu
and josuke as a team their friendship
feels believable and what's more is that
we've been there since its beginning
there's plenty of humor extracted from
this encounter too but once josuke
discovers that the being can transform
into whatever he likes he decides to
have him turn into a die so that he can
cheat in a gambling game with rohan
which he does and he does win it's a
pretty fun episode however one aspect i
appreciated about these episodes from
the second half is their dedication to
continuity rohan is still salty about
what has just transpired with the
gambling contest between himself and
josuke and this helps these standalone
episodes feel much more connected than
the otherwise would have in first half
of this season the next episode and
two powder feels like a car chase film
if that makes any sense
with a creative jojo twist after hopping
on a boss with jojo rohan notices a
small room he thinks something sinister
could be happening in within a tunnel
after requesting for jojo to help him
investigate which he declines to do so
by the way
rohan investigates on his own
discovering a stand that has the ability
to suck the nutrients out of individual
bodies
and interestingly has a massive range
and the ability to travel at high speeds
josuke does eventually come just in time
to help save rohan and thus the chase
begins between the rogue enemy stand and
josuke this is some of my favorite stuff
from the character by the way while i
hacked on about this last week quite a
lot i absolutely adore the mechanic of
josuke's stand at how versatile it is in
injecting excitement and creativity in
every conceivable scenario i mean
during this chase scene in order to not
slow down when approaching civilians at
a crosswalk he destroys his bike
leaps through the air with the parts
flying through the air and then
reassembles the motorbike before landing
again without any
loss of speed like that's such a cool
visually interesting thing and
a fun idea that makes use of his power
this chase is by far the highlight of
this two-part episode and josuke
eventually locates where the stand user
was staying after some investigation and
quick thinking on behalf of koichi that
points josuke to the room of the
hospital that he finds the stand user
apparently he's been sucking nutrients
to try to heal himself
and in retaliation for everything that
he's put josuke through josuke heals him
and beats the hell out of him returning
him to his once debilitated state
it's quite funny okay so let's talk
about kira interestingly instead of the
first half of the story which heavily
focused on
and concerned itself with the slice of
life character interactions and
exploration into the town of mario this
second half has the constant presence of
kira informing pretty much every episode
and the audience once again
are made aware of kira's new persona
giving us that extra layer of dramatic
irony the main cast aren't aware of yet
as we follow kira as he explores his new
world
and family for the first time and in an
ironic twist of fate
the one stale relationship on the verge
of collapse kira's host once had
now seems to be a much better fit for
him as a personality with his new wife's
romantic interests rekindled and at a
new all-time high and their financial
trouble is seemingly on the mend
thanks exclusively to kiera's choices as
an individual the scenes that he
participates in early on are clearly
there to give him something to struggle
against or bounce off of while the
others are trying to find him and work
their way towards the finale in other
words the hero team and the evil squad
are both sort of in this waiting phase
before they've reached the climax of
this story the first of these mini
adventures with the new keator concerns
a particular cat that his wife
accidentally kills and he buries in the
back garden the cat once possessing a
stand now has sprouted as a flower a
cat flower if you will this also
explains all of the suggestions i
received to name my bonsai stray cat
this manifestation of a cat flower
stand user that can shoot high-speed air
bubbles that can cause serious damage
are quickly taken care of by cure by way
of hiding it from light in his attic
now this brings me to the last and final
aspect of the story that i otherwise
didn't really buy
into and that's their son hayato
kawagiri you see while kira was
pondering to himself concerning his
current state of affairs and worries
out loud while practicing the
handwriting of his new host
the kid didn't just hear him but he was
filming him and this
isn't the only time this kid sets up spy
equipment either now
this criticism i have might very well be
the result of my growing up in an
otherwise rural part of the world
or it might be the fact that iraqi
thought the world would be much more
technologically advanced by the turn of
the millennium but
for a kid to have all of this genuinely
impressive spy equipment
seems really far-fetched to me and not
just that the fact that this kid has
surveillance over his father so
effectively
is essentially the only reason kira gets
found out at all in the end
every subsequent clue or connected dot
the gang unraveled during their
investigation only manifests uncertainty
because of the child's suspicions of his
father that came from these hidden
camera setups
alright okay that's everything i didn't
like so let's talk about something what
i did like
episodes 31 32 33 and 34.
so yoshihiro kira's father by random
happenstance notices and identifies his
son kira by looking at his fingernails
why okay so the hook of these episodes
is that they are all taking place on
essentially the same day july 15
1999. rohan takes a picture at the exact
same time hayato is investigating his
father giving him means with which to
learn his name because
his school bag has a surname on it and
josuke and okay to defeat another stand
user in the transmission tower thanks to
mr
alien man kayak are the buckets
transmission tower man reveals that
koichi has been eliminated and
in order to track down the dude that
took out koichi josuke implies the help
of someone he knows that has a great
sense of smell
and wide range stand this guy remember
him i do
and he finds him the gentleman that they
were searching down had stands that in
all honesty were
not at all anything that i would have
expected he can apparently suck people
into pieces of paper if they are scared
and he's already got koichi so
now he's sucky in josuke i love that
josuke hangs on to something from the
outside world and despite being sucked
into the i don't know
origami dimension using his crazy
diamond he manages to restore what he
was holding and thus momentarily drags
himself
out while this didn't work i once again
thought it was a super cool idea to
combine these two powers and what it
might manifest as thankfully however for
josuke and koichi for that matter they
are released after the guy that smells
good
saves them in a really creative way the
following episode episode 34 kind of
bugs me but
once again made rohan my favorite
character from this part
alright so he sort of gets this back
gremlin stand stuck
onto him and okay i know it's creepy and
all that stuff but
what bugged me about it wasn't the stand
or anything like that it was the fact
that when he reached out to koichi for
help
koichi didn't believe him i mean come on
man you're now living in a world with
stand magic an evil stand that's on its
back that you aren't allowed to see
isn't the weirdest thing that's happened
even this week for you
you have a weird bug man that can play
with sound and turn up gravity and he
can read your face like a book
during this section there's some really
funny moments watching rohan navigate
the world without showing someone is
back which again is something this
season of jojo did a lot with
creating these what-if scenarios that
otherwise wouldn't or couldn't have come
up in
any other show or story thankfully
koichi does turn up to save the day in
the end
because he wasn't sure if he was lying
or not but the real star of this show is
once again rohan who
unbeknownst to the creature on his back
positions him to look
down at the alley that you aren't
supposed to look down
ultimately dragging him straight to hell
and so we're heading into the end game
now as we follow kira stalk some kids
home
and ultimately murder them but
interestingly the entire act was
videotaped by hayato who despite being
from a small town in 1999 japan
has more spy tech than you can swing a
cat at this now puts kira into a
dangerous position
one he needs to rectify soon disclaimer
i am not going to cover the weird bat
scene because i don't feel like
outlining the narrative idiosyncrasies
of a weird bath scene
why don't you have a c episode 35 and 36
another one bites the dust this is a
really interesting and fun prelude to
the finale that incorporates aspects
from films like groundhog day but
with a distinct jojo twist and despite
it being the culmination of several
events that i thought
felt a little contrived this still
managed to be a really fun time that i
could easily get behind
all the while developing for kira a
brand new move to help him deal with his
enemies
oh yeah and this happened
something i really enjoy about araki's
writing of kira is how
vulnerable he feels in making the
decision to give the audience the
perspective of kira early on it helps to
put us into his shoes not to empathize
with him necessarily but to instead
feel the strains and pressures he feels
as people in his life skirt around and
press the lines of truth in his
character
causing him great anxiety fearing his
identity being exposed
there's a clearly observed almost
pathetic and desperate nature to cure
his character
particularly after his new son discovers
the truth about him and outs it to him
which i found in later encounters helps
to add a separate perspective in battles
to keep an eye on no longer are we
looking at villains that always seem to
be in control
kira's character's entertainment factor
largely comes from how he reacts to bad
news
and like the heroes struggles to make
sense of situations trying to solve
problems that present themselves in real
time with jotaro and josuke hot on his
tail
in this state of terror and anxiety over
being found out his father tries to calm
him down
when suddenly the same arrow that sought
out all of those other stand users
forces itself from the photograph and
into kira's body
before cutting to black from the depths
of this seemingly irreversibly
impossible to escape from scenario
came the following day now completely
calm and
brandishing a brand new hairstyle stands
kira
and his son now alive what the hell is
happening
this can't be a flashback his hair is
completely different the boy seems
driven to do something about his
situation too so
he seems to know what's going on kira
even meets him on his walk to school and
fills him in on more information before
leaving him and allowing rohan to
intercept the child
suddenly and without indication killer
queen jumps into the eye of rohan and
ultimately leads to his explosion
causing hayato
to relive that morning one hour in the
past
initially confusing the mechanics of
this new power of kira's become more and
more clear as time goes on while hayato
has experienced and recalls everything
that just happened and therefore will
happen
kira and everyone else are left unaware
of what exactly transpired though from
hayatul's reaction
kira is aware that this isn't the first
time he's relived this go-around because
he himself is aware of his own powers
and so now we understand why kira felt
safe apparently this new technique
called bites the dust
effectively puts a curse on hayato if he
reveals any information to
anybody about the identity of kira then
he will blow up those individuals
immediately and rewind time back one
hour with the most screwed up part being
even if hayato avoids these people he
blew up they still blow up
at the exact same time they originally
revealed that information to them
it's ridiculously screwed up and this
hour replays a number of times with one
instance even leading to a desperate
encounter with
everyone of the jojo gang trying to
understand hayato while he desperately
tries to prevent their deaths
[Music]
he doesn't succeed in that endeavor so
narratively araki has himself right now
in a corner so to speak so let's see how
he escapes this seemingly inescapable
scenario
using his knowledge of how the day will
progress and what kira is likely to do
hayato puts all of his knowledge to use
and does everything to stack the deck in
his favor
forcing kira to meet him outside on a
corner he makes use of the stan
cat plant that was in the attic to land
a considerable attack on kira when he
wasn't expecting it however ever the one
in control
kira once again takes charge of the
situation but thankfully that wasn't the
only ace of hayato's sleeve
as kira monologues about various
dangerous delicate details
he does so unaware that he's being
positioned in this conflict such that a
certain someone would show up
right behind him at just the right time
josuke hayato found a way of getting
kira to out himself without
triggering bites the dust an awesome
solution to this problem that saves
everyone including rohan while also
adhering to the mechanics of the world
it was a terrific piece of writing and i
really loved it episodes 37
38 and 39 crazy diamond is unbreakable
and
the finale now facing a critical set of
circumstances and a growing laundry list
of people that understand who he is and
what he's done
okuyasu and josuke ready themselves for
battle against the big bad of this town
and this arc the initial flurry to this
battle is interesting and it's really
the first time that josuke
and kira have fought which leads kira to
remark that his stand
josuke's is the perfect compliment to
his own i'm just gonna put it out there
i said that before i even saw this part
stakes dramatically rising once again in
an interesting turn of events
and role reversal okuyasu now in the
same situation kochi was in during his
and josuke's very first fight where
josuke now really wants to go and heal
his friend but someone
is in his way with his body now primed
to explode okuyasu seems to be a lost
cause leaving josuke only one choice to
heal him
and sacrifice himself in the process
yeah okay uh that was a much smarter
idea because hayato triggered the bomb
josuke was free to restore both of them
to perfect condition however even with
the restored body it looks as though
much like josuke's grandpa he was too
late to save okuyasu having been the
character he spent the most screen time
with by far
i really buy josuke's reaction and grief
over okiyaz's possible death
and with that it's time for the big
showdown it's josuke
versus kira possessing everything i
liked about the prior finale from season
one to three only without the world in
the line it proved that what makes these
fights great
aren't the stakes but the creative
writing used within them
exemplifying perfectly through another
genius implementation of josuke's stan
power
sending a designation bubble while
combining the use of this killer queen
and stray cat it's revealed that the
only reason the cure knows where they
are in the house
is by way of kira's father yoshihiro
ratting their positions out while in
their pocket jojo smokes him out and
then feeds kira the incorrect
information to blow up his own father
before hitting him with another big blow
from a glass projectile
used to hit his mark by way of restoring
it to its original location it's
a brilliant idea josuke finding ways of
making his healing properties of crazy
diamond work offensively
is always interesting and by far my
favorite part of this entire story and
what follows this brief window of
opportunity is a decimation on behalf of
josuke takira
josuke is far too fast and just as he's
about to win
the cat plan blocks his attack and it
seems it's time for akira counter-attack
moments from making contact with josuke
okuyatu uses his stand to manipulate the
distance between him
and the bubble projectile to josuke
killer queen's two best techniques
the heart attack drone and the bubble
bombs are therefore defused by the team
of josuke and okuyasu's combined
abilities
now surrounded by the entire team the
focal point of attention with no escape
in sight he hears an ambulance
and things to use bites the dust to
rewind time
this took me completely by surprise and
i mean completely by surprise
in what i and kira thought was a
successful use of
bites the dust with killer queen he
instead finds himself
here in this alley with remy through
this interaction we learned the true and
pathetic
faith that actually befell kira in his
final moments
beaten to a pulp by everyone and
eventually crushed to death
by an ambulance on accident the nature
of this ending is poetic and honestly
carried out by the very right person the
first person
kira ever killed now after having
fulfilled what she stated in the living
world for
to bring balance back to the once
trouble tone of mario after having cast
this monster into the abyss of hell he
will burn in for eternity she
and her dog can finally rest in peace
and that's pretty much diamond is
unbreakable i thoroughly enjoyed this
very different and in a way
stripped down version of the jojo
formula araki in this proved to me
that he doesn't need to have all the
bells and whistles of a big finale many
shonen would normally enjoy
instead he can make something feel
fittingly special and unique just by
being the creative mangaka he has proven
himself to be
what's more is the ending to this arc
specifically took me by surprise
with jonah josuke and joseph sharing a
nice and humorous moment before panning
across a montage of all the folks we've
gotten to know in moria this is a town
we've spent a considerable amount of
time exploring and getting to know
and watching everyone go about their
day-to-day lives really felt oddly
nostalgic
knowing that this is the end of our
journey and perhaps the last time we'll
ever see
any of them next week i tackle what will
be the final jojo part
in this series up until another english
localization pops up next week
i start my review on jojo's bizarre
adventure golden wind and i have a
feeling
it's gonna be
[Music]
appetite
[Music]